اذا سمحت لي انا سامر امر في الكاميرا على
ما تحتوي هذه النقطه وايضا يعلق على الامر
زميل
الكثير من الشحنات الى هذه النقطه فتوافد
الكثير من العائلات واجلائها بنفس الوقت
في هاي الاكياس عنا وجبات جاهزه للاكل
الفاصوليا مرتين ربطه خبز وبعض من
الحلويات الاساسيه اي مواجهه للاكل لحتى
العالم يعني
تستطيع انه يتناولوا بعض
الطعام طبعا هاي البسه
العالم هون
عم يجوا من اسطنبول او من المدن وسيله
شغلين
على النار وعم بتدفوا عليها طبعا
[موسيقى]
احنا شخصيا السيارات وصلنا اربعه ايام
الناس عم بيناموا بالارض
دعنا نذكر احمد وايضا بكر بنقطه التجمع
التي تتواجدون بها اين هي يعني ان كان في
اشخاص يودون الانضمام اليكم من الجاليه
السوريه او حتى التركيه
بلادي اسمه نادي حماه الاجتماعي موجود على
بعد 900 متر من الاوتوغار رحنا موجودين
هون واليوم نحن نشرنا على حساباتنا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي نداء لجميع سكان
انطاكيا الراغبين بالخروج لحتى يجوا
يسجلوا معلومات
مؤسسه واحده هذا الشيء غير كافيه يعني
احنا
بحاجز طول من الباصات الاف الح
افله وهذا الشيء للاسف غير يعني نتمنى ان
يصل صوتكم
نعم نعم
يتجمعوا في هذه النقطه ربما ينتظرون لحظه
اجلائهم الى مدن اخرى اكثر امانا في
الشمال التركي
يعني الاعداد اكبر من ذلك بكثير ويوجد في
هنا في جناح في النساء والاطفال الاعداد
كبيره حقيقه ما تعاني هذه النقطه يعني
الان هو مجرد وسائل التدفئه التدفئه ويعني
اماكن للنوم حقيقه نحن الان على الهواء
مباشره بعد قليل
ربما نضطر الى النوم حتى نستيقظ صباحا
ونباشر اعمالنا في وسط المدينه حقيقه لا
نعلم اي اي مكان وصالح للنوم ربما ننام
على الكراسي او يعني ربما يتجاوز هذه
الليله ونكمل ايامنا التاليه كما مرت
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه حقيقه اذا عدت
بالسؤال على موضوع عدد الضحايا في ولايه
انطاكيا مررنا كثيرا وكنت يوم ليله امس في
بث حي مباشر على شاشتكم تحدثنا عن ان
الشوارع ممتلئه بالجثث وكذلك الامر
صورت عدستنا هذه الجثث المنتشره والملقات
على الطرقات الاعداد كبيره حقيقه ربما
هناك اعداد مضاعفه في
هذه المباني التي دمرت بشكل كامل